next stop is so this is close to my part
I went to grad school at University of
Oklahoma and was you know physics and
astronomy there old school building it's
brand-new now it's really nice but I was
always jealous of the people up at the
National severe storm they they were the
slickest outfit on campus they had the
best computers everything I and one of
my outside advisors was from the
meteorology department so I just it's
constant jealousy and and of course they
did something incredibly important for
us anybody who lives in Norman for a few
years you will run into severe storms
many many times so great pleasure to
have Corey speak here and tell us about
what they're doing in terms of the
real-time decisions hopefully by the end
of this talk all of you will be equally
envious of me and the work I do but yeah
this so this work is taking place within
the the NOAA worn on forecast program so
that the goal there is to produce to
understand thunderstorm scale ensemble
model prediction forecasts in real-time
I work within the co-operative Institute
for meso scale meteorological studies
and national severe storms lab the
co-operative Institute is partnered with
the lab and and with the with the
University of Oklahoma
so in this talk I'll first introduce you
to warned on forecasts why we need it
what the goals are followed by an
introduction to numerical weather
prediction of thunderstorms which is at
the heart of war non forecasts then talk
about an experimental real-time or non
forecast system that we've been
evaluating each spring followed by some
notes about some of the major challenges
that we're facing in more non forecasts
namely a physical science challenge
which is the fact that thunderstorms
inherently have limited predictability
and of course some of our own practical
limitations enhance that that lack of
predictability computational challenges
posed by this this task of processing
this massive ensemble output in real
time and also interpreting the output in
real time and then and yeah the the
human factors challenge of actually
tailoring this this output to
forecasters who are operating in a very
time constrained environment and having
to act on this output in a matter of
seconds or minutes ok so first to
provide some context people in this room
and at home are probably most familiar
with kind of the next day type of
thunderstorm forecasting many of you
have probably seen the Storm Prediction
Center or SPC outlooks and by the way in
meteorology we have many many acronyms
we like to think that way more acronyms
and than other scientific fields I don't
know if it's actually true but there are
a lot of them anyway so so here's an
example of some SPC outlooks these now
go out to eight days there's an example
of a day six outlook going down to day
two and day one and as we get closer to
the event there's more specificity as we
get as we become more confident so that
these are a fairly long range then as we
get closer in time to the event the SPC
will issue the watches such as such as
tornado watches severe thunderstorm
watches these are typically several
hours before the event and are about the
size of a state now
and then when an event is imminent
that's when the local National Weather
Service weather forecasts office's issue
warnings and these are on the scale of a
county and are typically issued tens of
minutes to maybe an hour in advance
depending on what kind of phenomenon as
being forecast
we're not forecasts kind of resides down
here we're focused on the zero to three
hour time range but backing up for a
moment
most people including meteorologists
that are working at these spatial scales
they think in terms of forecasting out
to maybe 12 to 36 hours and that's where
most storm scale and WP numerical
weather prediction is happening right
now now when you're looking that far out
you're asking very different questions
than you are when you're looking at an
event that's going to happen within the
next few hours you may be asking
questions like around where and when
will storms start and end well will the
storm types be and related to that what
are the general hazards from these
storms this is more of a tornado day is
this a hail day flash flooding how
widespread or the storms going to be
what will their general motion be but
once you get down to more on forecast
scales now we're asking much more
targeted questions where will this
particular storm that already exists go
how fast will it move and how exactly
will its risks evolve and ultimately we
want to be able to produce probabilistic
guidance that looks something like this
so for an individual storm you know
probabilistically what how will the
tornado flash flooding large hail and
damaging straight-line wind risks evolve
over the next few hours
so one problem we're attempting to
address is the gap and guidance between
the watch scale spaceship spatial and
temporal skills and the warning scale
and it's clear why this gap and guidance
currently exists watches are currently
largely informed by nwp model guidance
that's issued up to eight hours in
advance or I'm sorry forecasts that go
out three to 12 hours and you know we
have plenty of guidance at those
forecasts lead times and also that on on
these scales like on the scale of a
state the environment the larger scale
environment that the storms are going to
evolve in already tells you a lot about
what to expect and so expert forecasters
could actually do pretty well without
nwp guidance although the nwp guidance
has proven to add a significant
additional value now once you get down
to the warning scales currently there
there is no operational real-time and wp
guidance and these very short lead times
and so forecasters in the best case are
reliant on their own experience and the
latest radar imagery that's available in
the worst case scenario a storm chaser
or spotter calls in a tornado report and
then a warning is issued but of course
that's that's very suboptimal in terms
of what you would like to get done the
best in predictions is it the way that
Warner forecasts is typically pitched we
focus on tornadoes and that's partly
because a lot of the highest profile
events are tornadoes and there are cases
where if we could get that tornado
warning out 30 minutes in advance then
and I'll get into this more a bit later
then we could warn
unit managers you know people in charge
of evacuating stadiums or hospitals or
schools that there's a you know an
impending threat and so there will be
some scenarios where many lives could be
saved that way but we're we're also very
concerned about other hazards to
tornadoes were the the first the obvious
first hazard to tackle but people within
the group are also now hitting flash
flooding pretty hard flash floods often
with some tornado events actually kill
more people than the tornadoes
themselves they were much more
disturbing and in terms of affecting a
larger number of people tornadoes were
which are very focused like the events
right right right to know how it was
wave tornadoes of course they're sexy so
yeah they really are but yeah I would
say flash flooding and tornadoes are
receiving the greatest attention right
now straight-line winds are just harder
to forecast it's it's not clear yet how
to best utilize the storm scale nwp
guidance for that and similarly for hail
that's that that's
Hale and winter probably the lower
priorities right now but ultimately that
they're all important same thing lies do
you in terms of your target audience say
do you distinguish between hazard to
life versus damage to property at this
level or is that is that aggregated do
you have different populations suddenly
decide billions versus working
population
so with these warnings aren't really the
warnings will contain text saying the
kind of standard text saying you know
that this poses a risk to life or
property we do it's not clear yet how
we're going to tailor the ultimate
output of warn on forecast systems to
the public likely we will divide the
public into at least two categories lay
people it's not clear yet whether they
could take appropriate action on the
probabilistic information that we'll be
issuing and I'll get into this more in a
moment but right now warnings are
deterministic you're in the warning or
you're not we want to go to a
probabilistic and this is actually part
of much a much larger framework called
facets where we're trying to get to away
from the deterministic paradigm or or we
want to supplement the deterministic
paradigm there would still likely be
deterministic watches and warnings but
complemented with probabilistic guidance
whether lay people could make effective
use of that guidance is unclear right
now and and that's that's why we need
social scientists to look at those
issues and and you know see you know
whether it would do more harm than good
to make that guidance available to the
general public but certainly for the
types of people I mentioned earlier for
you know people in charge of schools and
so forth they would definitely be a
target of this probabilistic guidance
now whether there's any way to kind of
actually separate the two in this day
and age you know it's inevitably some of
that probabilistic information would
leak out you know through some channels
to the general public but
yes so we're very mindful of the fact
that you know the you know the general
public is not this uniform category
there's many important subdivisions
within that broader category that needs
to be treated differently
okay so right so getting back to this
this gap between the watch and warning
scales
so again deterministic deterministic
probabilistic so here this is an example
of the type of forecasts that could be
issued based on more non forecasts
ensemble output where you have
probabilities of severe weather
occurring so this is an example of a
forecast that actually would have done
pretty well where the storm reports
indicated by these thoughts can be
concentrated in the areas of the higher
probability so that's what we would like
to see so the ultimate outcome of these
or non forecast systems ideally will be
that the Weather Service isn't able to
issue probabilistic warnings earlier
than the current deterministic warnings
and therefore provide advance notice to
to the groups I mentioned before so
here's a warn on forecast paradigm here
we have a you know an example of a
developing thunderstorm it's too young
to you know give any clear indications
of whether or not it's going to produce
a tornado for example but then the
warned on forecast ensemble would
produce this probabilistic forecasts in
this case the probability of a tornado
occurring at each location and then
ideally then you know the storm would
tend to evolve and then you know produce
a tornado generally were where the
forecast probabilities are highest
okay so this all hinges again on these
storm scale or convection allowing
numerical weather prediction models so
these are models with sufficient
resolution to simulate and predict
storms reasonably well and we found
through experience that four kilometers
is about as large a horizontal grid
spacing that we can get away with to do
this and that's that's mainly at longer
lead times once we start looking at warn
on forecast scales we're really looking
at three kilometers or less now of
course that's still a very that's still
very coarse resolution relative to the
processes that need to be simulated so
there are many physical processes that
must be parameterised including cloud
micro physics sub-grid scale mixing and
these contain large errors and I'll get
more into that in a few slides the
current state-of-the-art operational cam
we have is the high resolution rapid
refresh or her this is run a three
kilometer grid every hour and here's an
example of output from the her if you're
familiar with radar imagery like you
would see on the news this might look
like a radar composite to you and indeed
it does but this is actually a model
forecast just illustrating that these
models are capable of producing fields
that are quasi realistic now of course
there's a difference between producing
realistic fields and producing fields
that are accurate that that actually
match observations in a given case but
certainly this kind of realism is a
necessary even if not sufficient
condition to produce accurate storm
scale forecasts but yes these forecasts
have very large errors for a number of
reasons first storms have inherently
limited predictability in other words
perturbations grow nonlinearly so any
errors within the initial conditions or
arising because of limitations of the
model will grow rapidly forecast initial
conditions suffer large uncertainty and
bias largely because even with all our
instruments nowadays even would go 16 a
small portion of the atmospheric state
is
is actually observed a very small
percentage furthermore these observe
these observations have instrument
errors representativeness errors
especially Waddle errors are often very
large at these small spatial temporal
and temporal scales this is in part
because of the computational constraints
on model resolution numerix and the
physics parameterizations but also
because we have limited knowledge of the
processes that were trying to
parameterize so even if miraculously we
could suddenly suddenly there were no
computational constraints we could use
arbitrarily you know you know we weren't
limited in that way we still would not
be able to parameterize these processes
very well
so part of the solution to this it's a
it's a necessary peat of piece of the
solution is to use ensembles of camps
and not just deterministic single
forecasts so these are groups of camp
forecasts with different initial
conditions and optionally also different
physics parameterizations and even
dynamical course and by dynamical core I
mean the governing equations of the
model the numerix use integrate the
equations and also the model for in
itself because in with nwp models the
atmospheric state variables are not all
typically not all kohli co-located at
the centers of grid cells actually
there's different options you know you
could have this variable these variables
here and these variables there so that's
another choice that has to be made in
the design of the model and each has
strengths and weaknesses so anyway so
you can MIT you can vary the physics
parameterizations and even the dynamical
cores and these ensembles so this
accounts for the uncertainty in the
model the different initial conditions
accounts for the uncertainty in the
initial condition and so ideally the
ensemble forecast then provides a
representative sampling of the
probability distribution function of the
future atmospheric state in practice
that's certainly not always the case so
how do we initialize these ensembles
well this is done via data assimilation
where we optimally blend the latest
available observations with background
fields or first guessed fields that are
provided by the latest model forecasts
so the types of observations we
assimilate include surface and upper air
observations upper air observations that
are provided for example by aircraft or
balloon born soundings and optionally
radar in satellite data for warned on
forecast radar data as and this
necessity and satellite data has also
been shown to improve things
significantly in order to do the
assimilation we require background area
error covariance estimates that relate
observations to the model state
variables so in other words for example
if you want to assimilate a temperature
at a given location that's all well and
good but you also want you want
know how that assimilating that
temperature should update the
temperature at the surrounding grid
points and also the other state
variables at surrounding grid points and
this again is because we are only
observing a very small percentage of the
atmosphere so there are two main flavors
of dat assimilation in usin and storm CL
and VP there's there's variational data
assimilation which is just deterministic
and these use constant background Eriko
variances so in other words regardless
of what the current state of the
atmosphere is you're assuming the same
background error covariance which is
clearly suboptimal
ensemble common filters on the other
hand provide flow dependant background
Eriko variances and they do so by virtue
of using an ensemble of forecasts from
which you can actually estimate those
background error covariances modern KMD
a systems tend to use either the
ensemble common filter alone or a hybrid
ensemble common filter variational
framework but either way there has to be
some accounting for the flow dependence
of these background error covariances
okay so now getting into this
experimental born on forecast system
called newsy this is a weather adaptive
real-time cam ensemble that targets the
region of greatest severe weather risk
on a given day it's frequently updating
with data assimilation occurring every
15 minutes and forecast being issued
every 30 minutes it comprises 36 members
which is probably a bit on the low end
but again we're computationally limited
and then all the 18 of those members are
used for forecasts although we found
that larger are smaller ensembles are
needed for accurate forecast than for
the data assimilation itself and as I'll
show actually the newzeas performed I
think remarkably well so we're not doing
too bad physics is diverse it's physics
diversity is used again to account for
the uncertainty in these
parameterization schemes and the newzeas
evaluated every spring
in the NOAA hazardous weather testbed
that I'll describe a little later on by
scientists and forecasters and this is
actually a really important
interdisciplinary effort that is
absolutely critical to to testing and
evaluating the latest experimental storm
scale numerical weather prediction
products
okay so you'd stay that the newzeas run
in the spring forecasters look at the
Storm Prediction Center outlook for that
day and well my say forecasters but I
mean members of our team that are
actually running this experimental
ensemble they look at the latest
convective outlook and based on that
nest a domain typically of about this
size and that's the domain within which
the the ensemble forecasts are made we
can't just run over the entire US again
because of computational constraints so
each day and that this will change over
time but this is the latest
configuration as of last spring the new
Z is initialized at 1801 p.m. Oklahoma
time with actually what I haven't talked
about it's the hurry it's the ensemble
version of the herd that I introduced
earlier that provides the background
forecast with within which observations
are assimilated at this first
assimilation time and then after that
every 15 minutes the latest observations
are assimilated and then after each
analysis update the ensemble is
integrated 15 minutes forward in order
to provide the background for the next
analysis cycle and so on all the way
through late evening and then every 30
minutes either a 90 minute or a three
hour forecast is generated and again
that that's done using 18 ensemble
members so it's 18 individual forecasts
within that that green don't domain I
just showed so here's an example of what
these ensemble forecasts look like so
beginning on on the Left this is a
forecast from a single ensemble member
so did you know thinking
deterministically here the color shading
is reflectivity or a measure of
precipitation intensity and the gray
shading is a measure of rotation which
tends to correlate with how severe a
storm is including how likely it is to
produce the tornado here's a paintball
plot and
the middle showing it now all ensemble
members with different colors of shading
show it so showing the rotation tracks
from each of the ensemble members so now
we're getting a feel for the fact that
this is an ensemble product and then on
the right we have probabilities that are
calculated from these ensembles of
rotation tracks so now we're looking at
the probability of rotation exceeding a
certain threshold at each grid point
over the course of the forecast so this
is the kind of output that ultimately
forecasts forecasters will see
okay so as I mentioned mentioned before
storm scale predictability is is quite
limited we're all so computationally
limited so how can we optimize the
ensemble design such that we optimize
the the trade-offs that we're forced to
make for example we can't have
arbitrarily large ensembles or
arbitrarily fine model resolution but
it's not clear a priori how to optimize
that trade-off so how do we determine
what the optimal trade-off is well one
way is to construct idealized
sensitivity experiments that allow the
experimenter to isolate and
systematically explore the forecast
errors that arise from different sources
such as limited grid spacing or limited
ensemble size the drawback of course
being that we don't know what the
real-world model errors are and so we
can't really account for those in these
types of experiments so it's hard to say
how immediately those results can be
extrapolated to real-world prediction
systems on the other hand we can compare
real world forecasts such as those
generated by the newsy run using
different configurations so now we're
accounting for real-world model errors
the drawback there though is that it's
then difficult to verify due to lack of
observations and isolate impacts of
individual error sources because now we
actually have a convolution of different
error sources we can't isolate the
impact of any one error source so there
are trade-offs between both of these
experimental experimental frameworks so
I think it's critical to perform both
types of experiments and in some cases
it's possible to construct experiments
that leverage the strengths of both and
I'll provide an example of that in a
moment
we've also begun using machine learning
to try to identify forecast biases and
sensitivities in real-world output so
this this is a way to hopefully improve
the forecasts without having to improve
the models the physics parameterization
schemes because that's very difficult
and it may be a while until we can make
substantial progress in that regard
although it's still critically important
ultimately
so here's an example of an idealized
experiment designed to look at the
impact of a particular type of forecast
error and this this work we looked at
the sensitivity of forecast to the radar
storm geometry so by that I mean so here
this is a framework where radar data
were assimilated and the question was
how much does it matter if the radars
are far away from the storm at which
point that the your observations are
becoming very coarse in the area of
interest and how much does it matter if
the if the radars are collinear with
respect to the storm in which case
you're not getting very independent
information from each of the radars so
to explore this we use observing system
simulation experiments where we
simulated three different super cells
within three different storm
environments generated pseudo radar
observations from those simulations and
then assimilated them with an ensemble
common filter and I'd use the resulting
ensemble analysis to initialize an
ensemble forecasts and within these
experiments we fixed one radar at
greater than 100 kilometers from the
storm and reposition the second radar in
order to affect different radar storm
distances and angles between the radar
beams and I should mention that in
addition to measuring reflectivity as I
showed earlier Doppler radars measure
velocity in storms but only in the
direction of the radar beam what so only
one direction of the 3d winter field and
so the narrower this cross beam angle
becomes the less useful again the less
independent the Doppler velocities from
the two radars are so the question again
was what will the frequently poor radar
storm geometry that occurs within our
radar network fundamentally limit or not
forecast will we just not be able to get
very good forecasts because of these
observational limitations
and it turned out the answer was no even
in cases where we had very poor cross
beam angles and and both radars were
really far away we got pretty decent
forecasts so the so these are plots of
low-level rotation red being truth and
the shading being probabilities of
low-level rotation exceeding a threshold
so ideally you would like to see the
hotter colors primarily confined within
these red contours and this would
actually be a great forecast considering
what our current forecast skill is and
so and this was in the the worst
scenario that was tested so we
discounted that as a major source of
forecast error we next looked at the
sensitivity of forecasts to the model
grid spacing so we simply ran
simulations that were identical except
the horizontal grid spacing was varied
from
333 meters which is far beyond what we
can run in real time currently all the
way to four kilometers so these are
showing the reflectivity fields after
two hours so two hours into the future
one kilometer above the ground and if
you compare for example the two and
three kilometer results to the 333 meter
or truth' results you see there they're
pretty similar once you get to four
kilometers in some cases you get
dramatic degradation and that's why I
said earlier that I think three
kilometers is kind of the upper limit
model resolution or model grid spacing
that we should be using and warned on
forecast we also looked at sensitivity
to the initial condition resolutions in
other words what grid spacing do we need
to use for the data assimilation and
what are the observational requirements
if we simply don't have observations at
very fine resolution are we doomed from
the start now this is an example of a
hybrid real data / idealized
experimental framework that I spoke of
earlier here we took single member
analyses from from newsy analyses of a
real supercell thunderstorm super cells
are the
types of storms that tend to produce
most of the significant severe weather
in the u.s. we took one of those real
supercell analyses and down scaled it to
about a 300 meter grid and then
generated similar analyses except that
they were spatially filtered with cutoff
wavelengths that ranged from 2 to 16
kilometers so with the 16 kilometer
cut-offs and even the 8 kilometer cutoff
where we're smoothing the initial
condition quite a bit and we add noise
to these initial conditions in order to
generate ensembles and I don't have time
to go into it but it turns out this is
critical for identifying systemic
impacts of initial condition resolution
and other error sources in storms we
then integrated the original and the
spatially filtered initial conditions
out to two hours and then compared the
forecasts so these are the these were
idolized experiments in the sense that
we know what truth is and the we you
know so we had full control over what
errors were involved we isolated the
error gist to the initial condition
resolution but we also initialized from
the Internet and analysis of a real case
and and we use the same model and
physics as the newsy did so we're
representing all of the physics all the
processes that are represented in in a
real world the American weather
prediction models and also initializing
from an observational II constrained
analysis of a real event so this should
add realism to the experiment and what
we found was surprising in sensitivity
to the initial condition resolution so
for example if you compare and this is
for three different cases again if you
compare the eight kilometer panels to
the control you see that not a lot of
difference so whether you had a very
fine initial condition or significantly
smoother initial condition didn't make
much of a difference out to two hours
once you increase the cutoff wavelength
applied to the initial condition to 16
kilometers well now in at least one KCC
some bigger differences and due to time
I'll just say that we most recently
we've looked at the sensitivity of
forecast spread to the initial condition
spread how much is gained how much is
the uncertainty and the forecast reduced
by reducing the initial condition
uncertainty how much can we expect our
forecast uncertainty to be reduced in
the future as we have as we assimilate
more observations different types of
observations and therefore better
constrain that initial condition
uncertainty another very recent activity
has been using machine learning to
post-process the worn-out forecasts
output so that this has been done in two
ways first to facilitate evaluation of
the newsy system performance and also to
provide an automated and ideally a
reliable way to correct model bias
season in the ensemble statistics but it
remains to be seen whether we have a
large enough training data set to
actually do that effectively so
beginning with the first one
a colleague looked at the relative
impact of different features on the
quality of forecasts as measured by the
number of matches and the number of
false alarms so this was an object based
rotation track evaluation framework
performed in both all of the so using
the full data set that was available and
then restricting to cases characterized
by a certain type of environment that's
kind of unique to the southeastern
United States and that's been getting a
lot of attention recently okay and and
so three and this was using a random
forest technique so through this machine
learning he found that that the to
atmospheric variables that best
distinguished between matches and false
alarms are speaking over generally good
and bad forecasts were these two
variables which I won't get into right
now but just again this is just to kind
of illustrate some of the machine
learning applications that are
beginning to be performed within storm
scale meteorology this is very new work
applying machine learning to correct the
raw new ensemble output from ensemble
prediction systems so on the top we have
the raw probabilistic ensemble output
with the black contours being of the
verifications so ideally we would see
the the utter colors within the black
contours so you see that in this in this
case the raw and sambal misses a lot of
the rotation tracks now when the when a
random forest is trained on many
previous cases and then applied to this
case as part of a leave one out cross
validation exercise we see that the
probability of capturing these these
rotation track objects increases quite a
bit but we also have a high false alarm
rate so it's not clear whether we're
actually getting a better forecast now
by virtue of post-processing
statistically the dynamical output that
comes out of the the newsy ensemble but
this is work in progress again this is
just to illustrate one of the machine
learning applications that we've started
using so our real-time computational
challenges are not Pettit's exascale
like some of the other groups that have
been represented here but it still poses
a pretty stiff challenge every 15
minutes the ensemble of 36 members is
updated on the order of 10,000
observations and then integrated to the
next cycle every 30 minutes again a team
members are integrated forward for one
and a half or three hours there are
about 3.5 million grid points and on the
order of a dozen state variables at each
grid point the forecast output is stored
every five minutes so that's 8 18 or 36
output times per forecast each forecast
must then be post processed into over
100 probabilistic products and then
uploaded to a website
can be accessed by forecasters all
within about 30 minutes of the forecasts
being initialized it's there about 7500
images that are generated per forecast
and uploaded to the website as I'll
speak about more of these products are
designed to convey useful information
over the entire forecast period to
forecasters in less than 30 seconds so
basically we're taking a vet a vast
amount of ensemble output data and
trying to distill it into something that
forecasters can make sense of in seconds
to perhaps minutes so this is produces
about 1.2 terabytes of data per day I
know that that seems laughably small
compared to what others have talked
about the last few days but it I Oh is a
major bottleneck for us I'm I'd be happy
to hear suggestions about how to reduce
that but and I know at least when I was
more involved in this part of it do as
sometimes was taking up to half of the
total wall clock time
for the for the the running of this
ensemble system
so we run this on a crane machine we're
very lucky to have it it's reserved
entirely for warned on forecast research
and then running this news the
experimental system in the spring it has
over four thousand Ivy Bridge cores and
about three thousand of those are used
by the newsy we use several types of
parallelization first of all the
ensemble member forecasts all run
simultaneously that would be impossible
if we didn't have this many cords to use
we use MPI more specifically the the
domain of each forecast is tiled up so
that they can be processed independently
or in parallel and then stitch back
together at the end and this Cray has a
luster parallel file system which
accelerates the the i/o we actually it's
very easy for us to generate hundreds of
terabytes of storage both through the
newsy and then the the experimental work
the non real-time retrospective
experimental work going on in the group
so storage reduction is becoming a
bigger and bigger issue so to tackle
that we use netcdf for compression
that's a lossless compression I don't
know if you're familiar with netcdf 4
that's a file format that was developed
by meteorologists and it's in very
common usage within the atmospheric
science community we also apply some
lossy compression after the fact when we
start running out of space disk space
and I think we typically when we
compress we we typically retain about 16
bits of information and that's that's
sufficient for our purposes here's the
newsy website I mentioned before so this
is the sort of thing that a forecaster
would see and that you can see if you
want I'll provide the the link in a
moment so this this is the culmination
of a long period of interactions with
NWS forecasters and participants in the
NOAA hazardous weather testbed which
I'll talk about more in a moment
and being in the same building as the
Norman NWS weather forecast office has
big been a big boon for this we
researchers you we don't know what the
forecasters you know want to see in the
forecast we don't know how the
forecasters utilize information we can
look at a forecast
and think oh wow that's totally useless
but a forecaster may be able to glean
very useful information from that
forecast so we have some very
experienced that forecasters to work
what with within our building so that's
been very helpful for this and other
effort efforts we've actually brought in
a computer scientist to help revamp this
website and it's sophisticated enough
that now we're looking toward developing
video tutorials and pop-up Health images
and notes to actually assist forecasters
and other users and interpreting the
output so this website provides the
real-time guidance generated by the
newsy during the spring so you can
actually go to this URL and find all the
output from the last two Springs and and
that will again be active in 2018 so
finally more on the no hazardous weather
testbed pictured here this is a space
that brings together the research and
operational communities which is
critical because again researchers don't
you know I priori what the forecasters
needs are the forecasters are not always
aware of the latest developments of you
know within storm scale miracle weather
prediction and other applications so
this has been going on now for I think
almost twenty years and it has been
tremendously helpful and it consists of
again testing cutting-edge products you
know can the forecasters make use of
these you know how can they be better
tailored to the needs of the forecasters
and so forth so lots of
interdisciplinary research takes place
for example you know people made guide
for participants through simulated real
time experiments where they work a case
as if it's in real time and they issue
warnings and so forth and you know and
we can see how they actually make use of
some of these cutting-edge tools and I'm
not directly involved with any of this
but one of the things I find the most
interesting is you know the use of eye
tracking software to actually you know
see you know where the forecasters are
you
looking on the screen most of the time
and that helps track you know what kind
of products they're making use of so the
newzeas been tested extensively and in
the the hwt spring forecast experiment
on a number of ways and it's really this
multi method approach that that's
critical to actually providing an
overall holistic assessment of how
forecasters use the data which again is
not always intuitive so this can be
broken up into three categories pseudo
operational testing which is
retrospective evaluation of newsy
forecasts and derived experimental
forecasts real time operational testing
where members of the warning forecasting
work in real time with forecasters to
try to get them to use that the the
newsy output and their decision making
process and then and then learn how
they're actually using the output and
survey work where we try to gain a
better understanding of how well
meteorologists interpret the
probabilistic information that is coming
out of the the newsy system so dealing
with the first one pseudo operational
testing we've explored out short-term
ensemble forecast guidance from the new
Z can be used by an expert forecaster
who's actually semi-retired probably
with 30 or 40 years of experience really
high-quality forecaster and spring
forecast experiment participants that
produce one our severe weather
probabilistic outlooks so here's the the
new Z ensemble output now generate a
probabilistic forecast and then the next
day we'll see how well those forecasted
so this allows us to observe how
forecasters understanding use and
attitudes about new Z guidance evolves
during the experiment and all of an
example of that in a moment here's one
of the surveys that are that are given
to the daily spring forecast experiment
participants like some of the questions
may be what severe weather threats you
believe are the most likely based on the
new Z guidance and during what hours
let's see how confident are you in
today's outlook what products were the
most helpful in today's forecast
you know what news the product
and so forth so here's an example of so
here is a chart of how the expert
forecaster that I referred to earlier
how their product usage varied well
let's deal with this one first
this is showing how their use of
deterministic vs. ensemble products
evolved with time
so again deterministic being the more
traditional framework so not
surprisingly you know they in the
beginning they were more reliant on the
deterministic products that had always
been available but as time went on and
they learned to trust and value the
newsy output the probabilistic output
they began making much greater use of it
and that that's what we wanted to see
and we were further able to see you know
what kinds of products they were
spending the most time examining and I
was actually done by recording the
forecasters screen and then and then
after the fact you know actually looking
at you know where you know where they
tended to spend their most time let's
see can I remember this
it's not tremendously important I know
that yeah I can't quite remember because
it was a pretty technical detail that
doesn't really alter the the
interpretation of this plot sir I can't
I can't give it a more complete answer
than that they again this is this is
definitely outside of my wheelhouse but
and here's and so the expert forecaster
was also surveyed daily you know on the
use of the news the output and here are
some examples of things that he said on
most days news II was exceptional at
identifying which storms have the
greatest potential to become severe
newzeas a big help and forecasting storm
evolution so it's this kind of you know
feedback from forecasters that we really
rely on to Tevon I give how useful is
this guidance your examples of the
one-hour forecast that participants were
asked to issue so on the right here here
is the verification this is you know you
know this is what we this would have
been a practically perfect forecast you
see the storm reports or nests you know
nestled within the highest probabilities
here's the forecast that was issued
three hours before or two hours before
the event and a pretty decent forecast
and then the forecast improved the next
hour as we got closer to the event so
this was a desirable outcome but again
just to give you an idea of the kinds of
evaluations that are going on within the
testbed here's a success story from the
use of newsy and in real-time
NWS operations that this is the Elk City
Oklahoma tornado that occurred this this
was an ef-2 tornado 25 million dollars
in damage one fatality ten injured
here's the sum of the output from the
newsy for this event so the star is
close to where the the tornado occurred
and that the Weather Service was
actually able to take action on this
guidance and incorporate some unusually
specific wording into their tornado
warning namely there is a high
probability that tornado warnings will
be issued you never really see that the
wording it's you know the tornado
warning is issued or it's not
so they were able to use that guidance
and provide a bit more detail than they
otherwise would have been able to and as
you know as the forecasters become more
comfortable with the use of newsy
guidance then hopefully that this will
become a more common occurrence
finally interpretations of the new C
products how well do meteorologists
interpret probabilities so you know site
even from the general public well what
about the forecasters themselves so
testbed experiments were we're given a
survey to complete so wasn't just
researchers there it wasn't just
forecasters but also researchers and
some students and postdocs and they were
asked questions like you know given this
graphic which is probability of the
accumulated rainfall greater than point
0 1 inches interpret this graphic and
you know we've got a variety of
responses and in this case most of them
were correct people tended to have a
pretty good idea of what this actually
means not although you know one person
said oh this is a heavy rain event in
actuality we don't know this is just the
probability of minimal rainfall
occurring we asked about percentiles in
an ensemble based probabilistic
forecasts what do you think the 70th
percentile value of accumulated rainfall
presents of the 60 participants just
over half had a clear understanding of
what percentiles are so just under half
actually demonstrated misunderstanding
for example the accumulated rainfall
amount that 70% of the members are
producing no that's not right
accumulated rainfall at least yeah
region shaded represent the union of at
least 70% of ensemble members nope
that's not what it means
so you're you know we have a task ahead
of us you know actually training
forecasters to make use of the south but
when even the scientists actually didn't
do a great job of interpreting of
actually knowing what a percentile is
of course good students with the place
yeah what's that
congrat students were the best oh yeah
I'm really noticed it well it's a little
sample size but yeah alright so in
summary the no.1 on forecast program is
developing an WP ensemble prediction
systems that will ultimately enable
forecasters to issue tornado severe
thunderstorm and flash flood warnings
further in advance and with greater
accuracy and hopefully lower false
alarms a prototype real-time warnin
forecast system is being evaluated every
spring by operational forecasters and
research scientists this new Z provides
valuable probabilistic forecast guidance
for severe thunderstorms at zero to
three our forecasts lead times but the
limited predictability of storms in the
massive data volume of storm scale
ensembles post major scientific
computational and human factors
challenges so ongoing challenges include
the need to continue refining knowledge
of the impacts of different forecasts
error sources in order to better
prioritize improvements to the ensemble
configuration and to refine knowledge
about forecasters actually use the
ensemble output in order to better
design these worn out forecast products
and also to design forecaster training
modules for example we need to improve
the our ability to anticipate forecast
skill for individual events and storms
for example given our knowledge of the
current storm environment would we
expect there to be a higher or lower
confidence in the forecast on a given
day since the ensemble spread may not
always accurately capture that we need
to continue to develop machine learning
techniques for calibrating forecast
probabilities largely again to account
for the the biases in the model physics
ultimately again we're running out three
kilometres right now ultimately we're
going to need to scale to tens of
thousands of CPU cores in order to
achieve model grid spacings of one
kilometer or less that's been shown to
be especially important for tornado
prediction which isn't surprising
because tornadoes tend to be on the
order of a hundred meters in diameter so
likewise the real-time post process
saying generating all those
probabilistic images uploading to the
website that will also need to
accelerate we need to improve the
physics parameterizations errors in
which greatly limits storm scale
predictability but that's a pretty tall
order I didn't talk a lot about it but
verification is a major challenge that
challenge at these scales first of all
we have a lack of observations so in
many cases we don't have ground truth
furthermore even when we do even when
we're verifying against observations
that we actually have it's hard to
design objective error metrics that are
actually consistent with our subjective
interpretations of the quality of the
forecast traditional metrics just
oftentimes fail miserably the objective
metric says this is a bad forecast your
eyes say this was a great forecast how
do we design objective metrics that are
consistent with our subjective
impressions an object based approaches
are clearly a key to that but even but
it's not so simple as that
so I'd like to acknowledge the rest of
the ward on forecast team there's a list
of reference this year notice is
mentioned this morning you know about in
hiring high-energy physics papers
oftentimes have more co-authors than
words in the paper itself clearly not
the case in meteorology this to authors
to I but anyway out I'm happy to take
any questions questions from there might
be what is the option that you expected
people you don't know so fortunately
social science has you know rapidly
become a much greater priority in
meteorology and to explore questions
like that you know what what would you
know what should we expect people to do
with this information because physical
scientists we don't know we you might
know what we would do we're not
representative of the larger population
so but answering those types of
questions is critically important the
forecast could be perfect but if we
can't get the public to react in a
desirable way it's ultimately useless
instead of fanon samba love multiple
deterministic models is there any
prospect of actually building measures
of uncertainty into a probabilistic
single probabilistic model I'm not I
don't know if this gets to what you're
asking about
we do have ensembles that consist of
what we reached ensemble member uses the
same model except that there are there's
some sort of stochasticity built into
the physics parameterization so either
the empirical constants used by the
scheme's are randomized or there's
something that's called this the
stochastic kinetic energy back scatter
technique that also you know it's a way
of introducing noise in order to account
for uncertainty in the differencing
scheme it's it seems like you know some
of the uncertainties are quantifiable
you spoke of the initial condition
uncertainty and other elements of the
physics or you actually have a
reasonable estimate of where it is and
you know using different kernels or
different numerix seems like a rather
haphazard way of addressing
ultimately it's really hard to in any
sort of analytical way as you know
estimate what the forecast uncertainty
is ultimately we really because of the
non-linearity of the phenomenon we're
looking at aside from saying that
perturbations will grow rapidly we can't
say much more than that
so given you know even if we knew with
perfect precision what the initial
condition uncertainty was in a given
case because we're so uncertain about
the errors in a given case in in the
model itself the best we can do is kind
of a haphazard very ad hoc way of trying
to estimate what the forecast
uncertainty is so we just try to account
for you know the all of the error
sources that we can which could be you
know we know the model of numerics are a
source of error for example actually not
I mean that's actually a bad example
because in general at least with model
numerix more sophisticated numeric
should in general give you a better
forecast but but for example you know
our physics scheme so we have certain
physics schemes that we know tend to
perform better but in a given scenario
they may perform horribly so short of
actually using a variety of physics
schemes or at least taking that one
physics scheme and perturbing it in some
way it's hard to get at what what the
resulting forecast uncertainty is kind
of a related question in filters how
many hit them many unknown parameters
you have and you know do you have you
calculate your propagation matrix from
first principal your covariance matrix
for first principles or you learn it
from the
so we and so the first question how many
tunable parameters a lot much closer to
five and and those well the optimal
values of those will will again the case
dependent and you know we just as a
community we kind of settle on accepted
values that tend to work you know across
many cases but there but again they're
the optimal values will vary from case
to case for the as far as specifying the
initial background error covariances
there
okay so ultimately once you have a
background forecast like when the
newzeas run and it's initialized from an
existing ensemble so you can actually
inherit the background erica variances
from that pre-existing ensemble but at
some you know ultimately though you have
to start somewhere i mean that that
pre-assemble had to be initialized in
some way and one way to do that you know
so it you could initialize such an
ensemble using fixed erica variances for
example which is very suboptimal but
after you've cycled enough times it no
longer matters that you started from
such poor and there's no background
erica variances
along that line I wanted to try to
understand the the going from the
initial days model and then the
predictions do you that presumably
started with some servos that you had
they did but then you're cycling without
going back again to the full on daily
model that you started with right right
would there be benefit to being able to
go back to something that was more
updated at that scale that well actually
so the larger scale model is actually
still impacting in this case the new Z
model in that the the background
conditions or the boundary boundary
conditions the lateral boundary
conditions for this nested new Z domain
are updated by the larger scale model
yep yeah and one other question it seems
to me like given what you said about the
computational power you have available
if you have a ton of severe storm
systems across the US things get looks
like it gets a little dicey for making
what is their prioritization and where
you're doing things at that point or do
you have enough power to handle five six
massive state stores yeah we don't right
right now that the that slide I showed
with approximately 1000 kilometer wide
domain that that's that's as big as we
can do currently with at least with this
crane machine now ultimately this system
r1 like it will you know be
operationalized and will be running you
know in real time all the time and maybe
by that point it'll be running over the
entire US I look very likely not right
now I can't speak too much to the the
decision-making process that goes into
determining where exactly to put the
domain when there's multiple user severe
weather threats because I'm not part of
those decisions I actually not involved
indirectly I'm more of the kind of a
basic research scientist and
in the group so I'm not involved as much
in running the newsy but Allah the
decision would largely be determined by
where the highest risk is according to
the Storm Prediction Center any other
questions
oh it's like Cory again
[Applause]